oh boy it's here the sony a7s3 this is
the camera that i've been waiting for
for so
long and not just me everyone and
i'm gonna unbox it and then i'm gonna
tell you guys to go watch another video
where i do a very in-depth review of
this we went to utah and got a chance to
check this out early
and had the absolute best time and now
for the past
how long was that when did we go was
that like a month has been like almost
two months
i don't even it's time i don't know but
it's been
over a month since we haven't had this
camera so we've had to go back to
shooting on the a7 threes which are also
incredible cameras this is this is it
it's here and
now i would say my video life has
changed doesn't say my actual life issue
i got it sort of has
but video life there's no going back
okay let's open it
everyone keeps asking me why i have a
throwing axe in my desk i don't even
know why you would ask me such a
question
this seems like a very normal accessory
instructions what are you telling me
they're telling me something about sd
cards i am excited to get the new
compact flash card to really test
out some of the high-end snq 4k
120 recording features because i didn't
have one at the time of shooting the
previous review
usbc cable you can charge this with usbc
which is
incredible no recording time limits
4k 120 422
10 bit i'm gonna call my mom and let her
know
she probably already watched my review
so she's well aware
this is actually a very very precious
piece right here this is the battery
charger
this does use the z series batteries
like the a7 3
and a bunch of the other higher end line
camera
buddy look at this there it is there it
is there it is there it is there it is
wow it feels so heavy compared to the
a7c that they just came out with
that thing is so incredibly light but
this
is a beefy boy or girl
[Music]
oh it smells like high production value
oh wow
look at this no jingle
no jangle have you
met our friend who flip on screen
i was reading a review i forget what the
website was but it was like a super
professional review and
in one of the descriptions it called
this the flippy out screen
it was like the cutest thing ever it's
really what it is like what else are you
gonna call it
anything else in here like something
like maybe some breakfast
oh and look a little bitter eel here you
are
z series can never
you can never have enough batteries but
the good thing is the battery life on
this is really great
and since we've started using these
larger batteries in a lot of our shoots
i mean we just
they're it's incredible and most of
these cameras that we have right now we
started plugging them into usbc
so we'd hardly even use batteries oh
something else
for the power brick charger charge it up
charge i'm charged up so that's it
i've unboxed it now i want to send you
guys to the link to watch my full review
this video was really fun so it's
something that i'm very proud of and we
worked really hard on this so i hope
you guys enjoy it and basically my next
review
is going to be all of the other videos
that i shoot that look really incredible
it's because of this should i give it a
name
maybe like leave me some comments below
of what you think that i should name
this new camera and i will make a
sticky label and i'll i'll put it on the
camera
hello my name is
[Music]
subscribe for more videos because there
are so many coming out that it's
incredibly overwhelming
but i'm so excited so i'll see you guys
later
i'm gonna go charge you've got the
camera oh my god i
am taking trash i forgot the battery
god i'm going to stab myself and not be
happy
i have one it's fine i hear you so it's
going to be very dangerous over here oh
that's a drop
it's just drawing it is you can go
around but like i was up there on that
edge
okay um
[Music]
are you okay